(audience claps)
- The last time you were
here, what was it to promote?
Oh, the album!
- [Cam] Yes.
- Okay, now you're touring
and your daughter is touring with you.
How old is she?
- Yeah, she's 2 1/2 and
yeah, she's adorable.
- Probably got her own place by now,
living on her own.
(Cam laughs)
They grow up so quickly.
- I know these past few
years have felt like 18 years
at this point.
No, she's adorable.
I don't quite know how to
pull off touring on a bus.
She's pretty fearless, but
I think things that move
without her control,
that's like not her favorite thing.
So I'm hoping she'll like
sleep in a bed with me
and be okay.
- And is it like, "Mommy,
why is the house keep moving?
- Yeah-
(Cam laughs)
Probably.
- "Do we owe money, why do we keep moving?
"Why do we"-
(Jay and Cam laugh)
Now, speaking of families,
I heard yours is very competitive.
Is that fair to say?
- Yes.
Yes, I think it's pretty fair.
We play games like pinochle, I don't know
if you play pinochle?
- Oh, pinochle, yeah.
That's like a old-
- Well we got some old people in the-
- You're saying I should play it.
- I'd like to learn, I
think it needs a comeback.
That's what that sounds like.
- Then we had like great
grandparents would play
with grandparents, with parents.
So everybody gets around this one table
and it gets really intense.
- So great grandparents play with
grandparents play with parents.
So it's all old people.
(guest laughs)
There's nobody under 80,
apparently, in this game.
- Pretty much.
I mean we had a boxing bell installed
above the table where you play.
So, as you hit like a
really high bid, ding!
Or if you win, ding!
- So in case anybody's sleeping,
that'll wake them up!
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
No.
The things that are screamed at the table,
no one's sleeping.
- Is that what this video was?
Is this your dad ringing the bell?
Let's take a look.
(bell chimes)
- Adorable.
(guest sighs)
(Jay mumbles)
That's amazing.
- Waiting for the game
to begin, apparently.
- Yeah, yeah.